[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARTHAK GANGULY: Hi.
Welcome to Cloud OnAir, live
webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Sarthak,
and today, I'll
be talking about
building modern apps
using an API-first strategy.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
With that, let's get started.
Here's a quick
look at the agenda.
We are going to spend a
few minutes understanding
the problem, how Apigee can help
you solve those problems, some
of the high-level
architectures which are
needed to solve the problem.
We are going to
see a quick demo,
and then we should have a few
minutes for Q&A at the end.
The first obvious question
is, why should we even
care about this topic?
Why do you need to build
modern applications
using an API-first strategy?
And the simple answer is the
whole aspect of modernization
is such a huge driver.
We have to modernize every
aspect of our life, right?
We are modernizing
our phones every year.
our smart homes
and all aspects of our life.
And this modernization
also obviously trickles
down into every aspect of
an enterprise or a startup,
whoever it might be.
If you look at the IT landscape,
the software landscape,
that is changing a lot.
Normally, over the
last 10, 15, 20 years,
we would talk about our legacy
architectures, our websites,
mobile apps, partners.
Even mobile is
pretty new, right?
Mobile is maybe in
the last 5, 10 years,
when it became mainstream.
But that itself is
changing drastically.
If you look at where the
world is going towards,
we are talking about IoTs
and connected platforms,
like connected cars,
omnichannel strategies.
The backend systems are
moving more and more
towards microservices.
We are talking about chat bots
and AI-based bots, machine
learning.
We are talking about various
kinds of cloud integrations,
on how to integrate across
multiple clouds and SaaS
applications, how to
migrate your existing
applications from your
on-prem data centers to cloud,
and how to build
hybrid architectures.
So it is a drastically
different landscape
than what you have today.
A lot of this also is
delivered through APIs.
Keep in mind, when you
want to expose your data,
to the connected cars or to
your IoTs or to you chat bots,
there is an API
behind all of that.
The APIs themselves are
changing, as well, right?
The designs of the
APIs are changing.
When we first started
seriously thinking about APIs,
first there was RPC-style APIs
way back in the early '90s.
SOAP became really popular
in mid-2000s and all.
And then, now the world
has, more or less,
moved towards REST.
But there are other
forms of APIs,
like oDATA or GraphQL
or WebSockets or GRPC.
And there are so many
different just design patterns
of APIs, which are existent,
and that's a constantly evolving
landscape.
The security of those
APIs also changes.
So we used to have SAML
or PLS-based or IP-based
whitelisting or things
like NTLM, Kerberos
in the past, which
has mostly given way
to things like OAuth
or OpenID Connect
or JWE or even basic auth.
So what happens is, as new and
newer technologies come up,
some part of your stack adopts.
Let's say some part will
adopt JWE or OpenID Connect.
But you will have
some other stack,
which is still running on
SAML or running on mutual TLS.
There's even a
brand new proposal
for a security
standard called SPIFFE,
which came out last year.
It's an open source
standard from Google
for managing service-to-service
communications
in a microservices world.
So this is a constantly
evolving landscape,
in terms of API security.
The other thing which
changes are the consumers.
Previously, all the APIs,
which you used to have,
used to go and either serve
internal applications or maybe
a website or maybe one
web-optimized mobile app.
But now, you are building
native applications in Android.
You are building various kinds
of connected experiences.
You are building iOS apps,
IoT apps, smart homes,
all sorts of different
consumers who
these APIs are serving up to.
So all this change
inevitably results
in where you have an
IT infrastructure where
you have to manage a number
of different versions
of your APIs.
So you might have
some SOAP, some REST.
You have a few different
versions of REST.
You might have some
GraphQL APIs and whatnot.
You have different types
of security protocols.
You might have
different API standards,
which internally leads
to inefficient developer
on-boardings, right?
Because you need to onboard
more and more developers
from internal, different
parts of the organization,
or from your partners, or
the long tail of developers,
because you need
different developers
with different key
skill sets, right?
As we are going to
more and more different
discrete backgrounds,
different styles of APIs,
how do you onboard these
different developers?
How do you onboard the different
apps onto your platform?
And how do you release
faster and better--
the new versions of those apps?
How do you manage the
lifecycle of the keys?
Because, as you have
different consumers,
you need to have a much
better control on when
a certain key can be
invalidated, or, when someone
is not following your TNC, you
can mark that as a red flag.
And all of these challenges also
results in a massive challenge
with the overall analytics.
How do you measure all the
usage, errors, latency,
adoption?
Because you need
to measure things
from an operational
standpoint, right?
Across all the different APIs,
how is your average error rate,
or what's your average latency?
But you also need
to understand it
from the business standpoint.
How is your adoption of
the brand new API, which
you just published, or the
brand new version of the API?
And you need to understand
all the usage and adoption.
How is a specific
type of API getting
more used in a
mobile app context
than something
else, which might be
more popular with IoT devices?
Now, we have looked at
some of the problems
because of this dynamic,
changing landscape, which
your backend is changing
and your APIs are changing
and your consumers are changing.
Now comes the obvious question.
As part of this
changing landscape,
how can Apigee play a
role and how can Apigee
help you evolve faster?
So at a very nutshell, Apigee
helps by creating a platform.
So if you look at
the bottom-half,
that's where you have your
Google Cloud platform.
You have, maybe,
some other clouds,
maybe some
on-premises-based system.
And these are all
running a bunch
of systems, which are
exposing data, which
needs to go up to different
web and Android and iOS
and a different set of
consumers, essentially.
So what's a platform?
A platform is a
place where you can
bring these different
technologies
and the human aspects
of the technologies--
like the developers who are
building those backend systems,
the developers who are
consuming those backend systems,
then building the apps,
and, in the end,
users of the apps--
you can bring all
of them together.
So Apigee can help you, in
your journey of modernization,
by bringing all these
different entities together.
So in the Apigee platform, which
sits, as a facade or a proxy,
on top of your backend systems,
Apigee will take care of things
like providing you all
the right analytics,
from operational analytics
to infrastructure analytics
to business analytics.
It will help you manage all
the developers, the lifecycle
of the developers,
from the developers
who are producing the
APIs, to the developers who
are consuming those, as well
as all aspects of security,
translation, debugging, and
a whole bunch of things.
And we'll see that
a little later.
But the key aspect is
Apigee, as a platform,
helps you tie back together
all the technologies,
both in the production side, as
well as the consumption side,
as well as all the
different human elements
in this platform.
It helps you tie it
all back together.
Now, oftentimes, when we
are talking about this,
we get asked questions that,
hey, I would like to go there,
where we create this platform.
But over the years, I
mainly have built monoliths,
or that's what we
are left with, right?
So in a monolith world, you
would typically have all these
different capabilities-- like
authentication, authorization,
business rules, et cetera--
all confined in the boundaries
of the same application, which
are then consumed
by different users.
That's a very, very traditional
landscape in an IT world.
Now, people inherently
understand the problem
with a monolith like that.
So early 2000s,
the world of SOA--
Service-Oriented Architecture--
that gradually became popular
and became mainstream.
And that's when people
started to break
those individual components
into individual services.
We are still talking
about, primarily,
SOAP, with maybe some
SAML-based security
or certificate-based security.
But this is how, for
many of us, that's
how the architecture
looks like and not really
a very traditional monolith.
Now, as the world evolved--
it's 2018 for everyone--
we are no longer investing
new into SOA services or SAML
or SOAP or things like that.
Rather, the new keyword, the
new buzzword is microservices.
How can you build things
which are even smaller
and are easier to manage?
And we can leverage things,
like containers and Kubernetes
and stuff like
that, to grow them,
to scale them, in a hybrid
environment, either Cloud
or on-prem or
multi-cloud or whatnot.
So now, we have a
lot of microservices
as part of everyday stacks.
If you look at how enterprises
typically look today,
you will probably see a
combination of a whole bunch
of different things.
So lets start with the most
obvious on the right-hand side,
where you can see Cloud Foundry
and Docker and bare-metals
and VMs.
That's your traditional
on-premise environment,
when you have a data
center or a colo facility,
where you are either
running bare-metals or VMs
or running containers,
like Docker,
or doing other kind
of on-prem software.
From there, some
enterprises have
evolved to run Private
Cloud, where you are doing
not only Docker,
where you are actually
trying to run Cloud Foundry
and Kubernetes on-prem
and trying to create a private
cloud in your data center
or in your colo facilities.
Now, the next thing
is Public Cloud.
So you will probably
be using a whole lot
of GCP, maybe some other public
clouds in a hybrid environment.
And then, you have
the SaaS, where
you might be using things like
G Suite and using their APIs.
So the key takeaway is this is
a reality for every enterprise,
whether you are Fortune
2000 organization, who
has been in business
for 100 years,
or whether you are a startup,
who just started out of Silicon
Valley over the last few years.
The systems from where you're
consuming data and the systems
to where you are exposing
those data, that is becoming
more and more diverse.
So let's move on to--
now, oftentimes, when
you talk about this,
we get the feedback
that, hey, this
is not what our backend
really looks like.
This is probably where
we would want to go,
but this is not
what it looks like.
And that's the question,
which we get, oftentimes,
that my architecture does
not look like that today.
It might be true for some
parts of your business.
Maybe for some applications.
It may not be others.
But that's totally fine if
your architecture does not
look like that.
And that's totally fine.
Because, most likely, your
architecture looks like this.
So we talked about
this monolith,
and how monolith has been
a mainstay in enterprises
for many, many, many years.
So this is probably how
your application looks like.
You have a monolith.
In this case, we
are talking about,
let's say, a retail
experience, where
you have a monolith
application, which
has search, shopping cart,
typeahead, recommendations,
CMS.
And all these
capabilities are running
inside your data center.
These are exposing all these
capabilities, which are then
consumed by different web
applications or Android or iOS
applications.
So monolith exposing some
APIs, which are then consumed
by those web, Android, iOS.
Oftentimes, you
probably don't even
know the existence of the
APIs because of two reasons.
Either the monolith, down
below, exposes your SDKs,
and the SDK, in turn,
hides those APIs.
Or maybe the monolith, itself,
provides you a direct hook
into the web, Android, iOS.
It's the same team
who builds those.
And there is a very
deep integration
between those consumer-facing
applications and the backend.
But the challenge is
that now the front end
and the backend, those are
very tightly integrated.
So what we need to do is we need
to create a proxy or a facade.
We need to separate
those two things out.
And that's where Apigee fits in.
Apigee acts as a proxy
or a facade, which
sits in between that
backend layer, where
you have the monolith, and
you have the frontend layer.
So first and foremost,
this gives you
a tremendous flexibility
on the frontend team
to do things differently,
at a different pace,
than what would
happen at the backend.
Now, let's look into how will
that happen in real life.
So let's say you
have this monolith.
And now the backend
team, they decided
that we need to break
down this monolith.
We want to create a
few microservices.
Let's say we want to break down
the search and the typeahead,
and write some new services,
maybe property lookup
and whatnot, which is not
available today as part
of the monolith backend.
And now they are writing
this thing in microservices,
in GKE, running on
Google Cloud Platform.
Now, because Apigee is
sitting, as an obstruction
layer in front of this backend,
while the backend teams are
making those changes, they
are moving the services
to Google Cloud
Platform, which takes
a long time, which takes maybe
six months, a year, two years.
The frontend teams,
they are not impacted,
because they are getting,
still, those same APIs.
And Apigee is taking care of
translating them, mediating
them.
So when the Google
Cloud Platform-based--
and there's where the
microservices are built,
so the APIs might be
exposed as JSON over REST,
whereas the monolith
might expose SOAP.
Apigee will make sure that
what the Android and the web
and the iOS team see is single,
uniform APIs, irrespective
of what the backend is.
It's the same security.
It has the same
versioning structure.
It has the same, let's say, the
layer of caching and everything
else, like the backend,
whether it is in a monolith
or whether it is in GCP.
So what it leads to
is the frontend team
now gets isolated.
As you can see, we can
now create one nice box
around those different
frontend teams.
Because you might
have a different team
for web, a different
team for Android,
a different team for iOS.
And now there is
a nice box, where
they can work themselves
at an arm's length
from the backend team.
So we are now trying to
break away from the paradigm
that the backend and
the frontend teams
are very closely
knit together, where
every feature on the frontend
results in a deep code
change at the backend.
Like where we have
seen things like,
if you want to build a new
feature in an Android app,
it might result in
having a stored procedure
change at your database level.
That's obviously not
ideal, and it slows down
the whole process.
So now, what you
can see is, maybe
as part of this architecture,
what the retail customer wants
to do is they want
to move everything
onto GCP as different services.
And they want to keep,
in their private cloud,
or in the data center, they
want to keep their shopping cart
application.
Because it doesn't make sense to
rewrite that as a microservice
or whatnot.
While they're doing
that-- as you can imagine,
this is a massive change.
They are doing
massive reworking,
and it is happening
over years, maybe.
Instead of the frontend
team being slowed down--
where they have been
asked that, hey, we
are making these massive
changes at the back end,
please make your changes slower.
Instead of that, they actually
added brand new capabilities.
They might have added a new
Google Home integration,
or they might have added
some other native mobile apps
or some new web apps.
So the beauty with
Apigee is you can
create this facade
or a proxy layer,
where you can have the frontend
teams building new apps faster,
going through faster
release cycles of the apps,
while your backend goes through
these tremendous transformative
changes, where you are
shifting your backend,
either from monoliths
and taking it
to a lift-and-shift of cloud,
or building out a hybrid cloud,
or building out microservices,
breaking out of your monolith
into microservices.
Whatever shape or form
those changes might be,
Apigee will help you isolate
those changes at the backend.
And your frontend
teams will still
be able to innovate at a lot
faster pace than probably
where they were before.
Now, how Apigee does that?
This diagram talks
about something
which is more commonly
known as a two-speed IT,
or a multi-modal IT.
These are the words which have
been thrown around in the IT
world in the last few years.
So what does it mean?
Down below, where you see
the CRM and the financials,
HR, supply chain,
and all of that,
that's the system of records.
That's the layer which you
hardly ever want to touch.
You don't want to go and
change your users' database
schema every few days or
even every few months.
Maybe that changes once
every couple of years.
So the pace of change over
there is very, very slow--
a matter of years.
But at the top, you have
your systems of engagement.
So this is where you have
your web apps and mobile apps,
either employees' apps
or consumer-facing apps,
or partnered apps and whatnot.
Now, at that layer, you
need to move a lot faster.
You need to move in
a matter of days.
If you have an app
out in Google Play,
and you get a feedback that
something is not right,
you cannot wait for
18 months to fix it.
You cannot even wait for
maybe 18 days to fix it.
So that's where Apigee
comes in, with this ability
to manage the security, the
scalability, the analytics,
manage all the developers.
Apigee acts as a
cushion, where it takes
those systems of records--
the slow-moving
layer-- and makes it
into a system of
engagement, where
you can move a lot faster.
So this is an example of how
Apigee fits in, in a Google
Cloud Platform context.
So let's say you are
writing your backend.
You have the system
of records down below,
which are untouched,
like your CRMs
and financials and inventory
and HR and whatnot.
Then you are using Google
Cloud Platform, on top of that,
to do a whole bunch of things.
You might be running Google
Cloud Pub/Sub, logging,
Dataflow, Bigtables, computes,
and things like that.
The Cloud Pub/Sub or the
login or the business logic,
which is running in
App Engine, those
are then all exposed out
to your clients, which
are maybe IoTs or
mobile apps or web apps
or partners or whatnot.
Apigee sits as a facade,
in between these two,
and makes sure all
the data, which
is exposed from Google Cloud
Platform, goes through Apigee.
And Apigee takes
care of managing
all the APIs, the security,
the operational aspect,
the analytics.
It creates a developer
portal through which
all the developers
on the client side
can get access to
those APIs easily.
Do the bot protections-- so
if you get attacked by spams,
Apigee has bot
detection built-in.
If you want to even
monetize some of those APIs,
that capability also is built
in as part of that platform.
Now, these are,
capabilities-wise,
what you are looking
at from Apigee.
So if you look at Apigee, the
two key trends on both sides
are the machine
learning and the AI,
which we use at many
parts of the platform.
Down below is the runtime,
where you have the Enterprise
Gateway and Istio.
Then you have a
mediation engine,
which takes care of
security or transformation,
from SOAP to REST,
or XML to JSON.
You have connectors, in which
you can write in Node or Python
or things like that.
You can build orchestrations.
When one call comes
in, you split it out,
and a few different calls
go to the southbound.
Then there is all
sorts of analytics,
from business analytics
to operations analytics.
And then you have the
whole developer ecosystem,
where you have the API catalogs,
you have the client SDKs.
You are taking your APIs
and creating products.
So Apigee kind of makes
you treat your APIs
as individual
products, just like you
will treat your every
other go-to-market product.
And then, you can create
an API marketplace,
or you can actually sell those
APIs using the monetization
capabilities.
So this is how the API platform
looks like, capabilities-wise,
at a very high level.
We are going to now jump into
a quick demo of everything
we talked about.
I have a very simple setup.
The demo setup is I have two
different applications, which
is serving some hotel's data.
We got some hotel's
data loaded up into GCP.
And then I have a
Node.js app, which
is running in Google Compute
Engine, in regular VMs.
And then I have a
Spring Boot app,
which is running in GKE, the
Google Kubernetes Engine.
And both of these
apps are exposing
APIs, which are then
proxied through Apigee,
and goes to different consumers.
In the Apigee world,
the different consumers
are represented by apps.
So I have two different apps
which are consuming those APIs.
One interesting thing is we are
using the VM Compute Engine.
That is kind of reminiscent
to a legacy application,
how you would run your
traditional VM-based apps.
And the Spring Boot app,
which is running in GKE,
is like your modern application.
We also have an Apigee
developer portal.
This is where we expose all the
details of those APIs, which
can then be subscribed
to and then consumed
by the developers, who wants
to build the different apps.
With that, let me switch
screen and jump into the demo.
So what you see is a
picture of a nice hotel.
So this is our fictitious
hotel, and this
is where the hotel's
developer portal is.
If you are not familiar with
what a developer portal is,
a great example for
you to take a look at
is go to developers.Google.com.
This is one single page
through which Google interacts
with all these developers.
And please keep in mind, this
is not only for public use cases
or for long tail of
developer's use cases.
If you are a large enterprise,
if you are building APIs
internally, and if you have
hundreds of developers--
very similar to this,
like a dev portal--
it's extremely easy to
build this platform,
to build this ecosystem, inside
your enterprise, as well.
So please take a look at
this developers.google.com,
this developer portal.
And what Apigee helps you to
do is build a developer portal,
just like that, for
your enterprise,
either a private developer
portal or a semi-private--
means it can be invitation-only
to your partners--
or you can have it a true
public developer portal.
So this is one such
developer portal,
which I built for the demo.
We call it Hotels R Us.
And as part of this dev
portal, we have some APIs.
We have some pretty
simple-looking pages.
But let's say I have this API
called cmap-demo, cmap-hotels.
And there are a
bunch of hotels APIs.
Here, I can see an
API for Get All hotels
or Get a hotel using
a particular hotel
name or reviews or
inventory or whatnot.
Now, what I can do is
I can simply go here,
and I can try out this
API, and I can execute it.
And I can see the
request and the response.
Now, this is based on open
APIs, which was previously
known as Swagger.
So when you import a Swagger
definition, or an open API
definition, into Apigee,
Apigee can automatically
create this dynamic
page for you.
The beauty of this
is, without something
like this, previously, you
would have to probably request
access for an API, have to
wait for a few days, if not
few months.
Someone would have
to give you access.
Documentations, with
maybe a PDF, and then
you take those and then
write some client code.
And then only you can make the
first call to your API, right?
This is a process
which would have
taken a long time, a lot of
trial and errors, not easy
to get support, and
things like that.
So now, with a
developer portal, anyone
can come and can
learn about the API.
At this stage, you are
accessing a sandbox environment.
You will not have access
to the production.
When you want to get
access to the production,
then the developers have to go
in and log in right over there,
and he can ask for support
for various things.
They can log in.
They can get keys.
You can then approve those keys
for getting used in production.
And only when you are certain,
about what kind of app
the developer is building
and things like that,
you can have him use
your production APIs.
And Apigee takes care of
creating the segregation,
between sandbox
and the production,
and how do you do
app promotion, how
do you certify your developer,
and all that kind of stuff.
Now, let's see an Apigee screen.
So this is what we
call the Management UI.
So when you log into Apigee,
at just apigee.com/edge,
in your SaaS environment, this
is what you are going to see.
One of the first things, most
likely, you are going to do
is create an API proxy.
So the proxy is
really the facade,
which is separating out your
backend from the frontend.
So over here, I have a
whole bunch of-- sorry--
I have a whole bunch of facade,
a whole bunch of proxies.
But I'm going to open up
this particular proxy.
If you can see, it has
two different backends
which it talks to.
So one is that legacy
backend, which I talked about,
which is the legacy Spring app.
And the other is the
more modern application.
And both of these are exposed
as one single application.
So the immediate beauty is
that, when a consumer is trying
to call-- they are going to be
called as endpoint /v1/hotels--
they don't know
whether, downstream, it
is going to the
legacy application
or to the modern
GKE-based application.
That is something which Apigee
can take care of dynamically
and can route it to
different backends.
So when you move on to this
particular screen, called
Develop, this is where it
becomes a lot more interesting,
and you can actually see all
the different getallhotels,
getallhoteldetails, and
all that kind of stuff.
So these are the
different API calls,
which Apigee is configured
to process right now.
And I will not spend
a lot of time on this,
but this is what we call a
Proxy Editor or a Policy Editor,
where, using different
kinds of policies,
you can configure
all sorts of things,
from put the right
amount of Quota
or Spike Arrest or
caching or security,
and do orchestrations and
version management and things
like that.
Let me quickly jump onto
this screen called Trace.
So Trace is a live debugger.
If you have ever written a
code, you have most likely
used a debugger in your IDE.
So Trace is such a debugger.
So this is where I have
a script running, which
is sending some API calls.
And I can see those API
calls actually coming in.
And I can actually click
on a particular call.
And I can see how
the call came in,
the different policies, which
it is invoking, like there it
is invoking a policy
to verify API key,
a policy to remove
the quota policy.
There are some conditions.
And finally, the call
goes to the backend.
I can actually,
then, go down and see
all the different parameters
that particular policy
affected.
So this is an
awesome way for you
to debug things in real life.
And you can export
the session and can
do an offline tracing later on.
Now, let me move on to a
little bit different screen.
So we created this UI, a
very simple hotels app.
If I click down below,
you will actually
see it has been configured
to use that v1/hotels,
and I'm passing an API key.
So as part of the demo
setup, I created two apps.
One is a legacy app,
and one is a modern app.
Both of these apps calls
the same API, v1/hotels.
Now, based on the API key, with
which the app is configured,
the call will go to
a different backend.
So Apigee is checking,
at that API key,
and is discerning which
one of the backends
this particular app
is configured to.
So if I actually go ahead and,
let's say, search for Seattle,
I will get all the details
from that backend application.
So this is a very,
very simple demo.
But what we are hoping
the key takeaway
is you can see the simplicity,
that you are exposing
one single interface to
all sorts of applications,
whether your legacy
applications, which
you are scared to touch, because
the original developer is
no longer with the company
for many, many years,
or to the modern Android apps.
All of them get
the same interface.
And then Apigee can
dynamically redirect them
to different backends.
And you can do so
many other things,
like manage different versions,
manage different styles
of APIs, different security
capabilities of the APIs
and whatnot.
One other thing, which I
wanted to show you guys today,
is the analytics capability.
Because, as you have more and
more different styles of API,
a higher usage of those APIs,
larger number of developers
using those APIs, the analytics
becomes very critical.
Because you need to
understand, very precisely, how
each developer or how each
app is using those APIs,
at what error rate, what
latency, what throughput,
what is a business
justification for an API,
and things like that.
So I have one analytics,
which is open,
which, over the last
one day, is showing me
what's my overall total
traffic, my success versus error
rate, my average response times,
my traffic by different proxy.
So it might be I have a user's
API and I have a catalog API.
How do I know which
API is getting
used more often and at what
error rate and what throughput
and what not?
I can look into things
like API monitoring,
which actually helps me
see what are the last five
hours of my latency,
or the error rate,
and what is the total
traffic for individual APIs.
I can actually go in and
can drill down and see, OK,
I can configure
thresholds that, hey, I
want to get alerted
every time the throughput
or, let's say, the error rate
goes beyond 0.1% and things
like that.
It looks like I have
a little less data
than what I anticipated.
So we'll move on to some of
the other analytics, things
like developer engagement, which
is really popular with product
managers.
Here, you can see, I can look at
all the different developers--
the details like
proxy name and things
like that, then what
apps they are using.
I can then drill
down and analyze
individual applications.
So I can say, hey,
this developer
is making a lot of calls
from their Android app.
And I want to see
how their pattern is
different from last seven
days versus this seven days
and things like that.
There are a whole bunch
of other analytics,
like error code
analytics or Geomap,
which helps you to get
an awesome overview
of analytics data,
or the traffic coming
from all around the world.
And you can see
that, immediately,
calls coming from
Virginia, and I
can drill down and see where,
in Virginia, the call is
coming in from.
You can see your traffic, error
rate, average response times,
and all those things,
and how are they
distributed over the world.
So I'm going to pause there.
This is just-- please
keep in mind this
is just a very high-level
overview of Apigee,
and we have not even
touched probably
10% of the overall
platform capabilities.
There's a lot more.
Feel free to try out the
platform at Apigee.com.
Just go and sign
up, and you should
be able to get the
same interface as you
are seeing now.
And I'm going to pause there.
Please stay tuned for Q&A. We
have a few questions coming in
during the whole session.
We'll be back in just
less than a minute.
All right.
It looks like we got a few
questions during the session.
Let me try to address
them as best as I can.
The first question is, "Can I
use Apigee even if we are not
using Kubernetes or GKE?"
The answer is yes.
So Apigee is very much
backend or platform agnostic.
Apigee only cares
about HTTP or HTTPS.
So it doesn't matter
whether you are running GKE
or even if you're
running in GCP.
You might be running
your private cloud,
your on-prem data centers,
might be Cloud Foundry,
or whatever it might be.
As long as that application
talks HTTP or HTTPS,
you can use Apigee
on top of that.
And you can also
use other protocols
using custom connectors, using
things like TCP-based protocols
and things like that.
So the answer is absolutely
yes, primarily HTTP and HTTPS,
and other protocols
using custom connectors
The second question is,
"I don't have mobile apps.
Is Apigee still relevant?"
Absolutely.
Interestingly, you
will actually see--
traditionally, if you
look at how enterprises
have used Apigee, one of the
starting points, in many cases,
is they use Apigee to streamline
their APIs internally,
irrespective of where
the mobile apps are,
whether you have mobile apps
or web apps or IoTs or whatnot.
Because a challenge,
which typically happens
at almost every
enterprise of every size,
is that, over the years,
people write different kinds
of APIs, different styles,
different versions.
How do you even get a good
control on those APIs?
Who are using those APIs?
What is the usage pattern,
all that kind of stuff?
So yes, we have a
lot of customers who
use Apigee with mobile apps.
But who the consumer
is, that's kind
of not so much critical, as
long as a consumer talks APIs,
or the consumer talks in HTTP
and HTTPS-based protocol.
So just to reiterate, the
answer is absolutely yes
for the second one.
Third question, "Can I have
different security protocols
for my different APIs?"
This is actually becoming more
and more relevant and more
and more common.
Because, as we see
enterprises, who
have started modernizing-- even
companies who are pretty new,
who have been in existence
even for like five years,
they may have started
with something
like OAuth and bearer tokens.
And now, you might have
evolved into JWTs, or OpenID
Connect and other
protocols, or maybe SPIFFE,
which I mentioned earlier.
Obviously, other
enterprises, who
have been there
much longer, they
might have a lot
of older protocols,
like Kerberos or
SAML and whatnot.
What you can do with Apigee
is you can do something
called credential mediation.
What it means is, on the
southbound-- that is,
Apigee to the backend--
you will have these individual
different protocols.
And the northbound side,
which is the client to Apigee,
you can have one
standard protocol.
Maybe you understand it as
an OAuth, maybe a couple
of different flows of OAuth.
And you can have the
client talk to Apigee
using just those
two OAuth protocols.
And then Apigee,
on the southbound,
will translate that to SAML or
JWT or OpenID Connect or TLS
or whatever might be applicable.
Great question.
The next one, "Can Apigee
analytics data be exported?"
Yes.
There are a few
different options.
So all the analytics
data which you saw--
and a lot of others,
which you did not--
you can export that to an API.
You can do pretty
much a raw export,
or there is a pretty
powerful query syntax
through which you can export
just parts of that analytics
data.
And there is also
native integrations,
with things like BigQuery,
where you can directly
export all the data to
BigQuery, so that you
do further analysis in GCP.
Next question, "How
can Apigee manage
different versions of my API?"
Again, great question.
So there are two aspects
to that question.
One is how the platform
can do, and one
is what are the best practices
of version management?
So let me address the
first question first.
So you can manage--
for Apigee, different
versions of APIs
are just different APIs.
Whether you represent those
versions as query parameters
or through headers or
through foreign parameters,
those are just
different endpoints.
And Apigee just will
manage two different APIs.
Apigee will also provide you
analytics out-of-the-box,
through which you can see
how the adoption of different
versions are.
And you can take
business decisions,
when to cut off a
specific version,
or which version is
getting adoption,
and how can you fine
tune and adjust those?
Now, in terms of
best practices, we
have seen a lot of
versioning over the years,
and we have best practices
on whether you should
do versioning through URLs
or through foreign params
or through headers,
how it should
vary based on the style of
APIs and things like that.
You can go over to Apigee
blog, and you can learn
a little bit more about those.
The final question, "Can
Apigee manage APIs of SaaS
applications we are consuming?"
Absolutely, yes.
The answer is very
similar to the first one.
As long as there
is an API, as long
as there is an HTTP or
HTTPS-based protocol,
absolutely, Apigee
can address those.
So with that, that's the
last question which we have.
If there are any
follow-ups, we are
going to address those online.
And stay tuned for
the next session,
"AutoML Vision, Making
Custom Image Analysis
Possible for Every Business."
Thank you, and have a great day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]